nice Greg McElroy works for the
mothership covering college football
former Alabama quarterback he's got a
national title to his name good game
great game or just great finish last
night Greg I'd say great finish but I'm
gonna be a prisoner of the moment Dan
and I'm gonna say that was just a great
game right I mean it was just it was
dramatic there were moves made in the
game that you just don't see I mean how
often do you see a former SEC Offensive
Player of the Year get the hook and all
of a sudden the true freshman goes in
for his first meaningful snaps I mean it
was like a storybook ending to what was
an Academy award-winning drama I mean it
was just it was great cinema man I loved
watching it and I thought the execution
for the most part - was outstanding
which which made it much more watchable
and enjoyable - what do you think the
Alabama locker room was like at halftime
I have a feeling there were some table
split that's really I mean oh you think
he was yelling screaming oh my goodness
I don't even I yes okay I've seen him
irate on a few different occasions many
of which as a result of my play oh I do
think that given the way the game was
going I have a feeling he was very upset
with the plan
- offensively I think he had a long
conversation with Brian tabled the
offensive coordinator and I think coach
daven really said man we we gotta start
throwing it downfield I mean because
it's ridiculous how much Georgia was
squatting on everything underneath and
they were having very little to no
success trying to run the football they
really had one play running the football
and offense in the first half and that
was on the quarterback draw when Jalen
made a couple guys miss so they had
nothing going and I don't like the plan
at all by Brian table coming in because
there was no aggressiveness to it next
thing you know - is in there that's
throwing the ball downfield almost every
snap so I thought it was a really good
job of adjusting but I do sense that
there was a lot of frustration and then
on the flip side a lot of relief on the
back half of the game because I've never
seen Nick Saban so happy at the end of
the game knowing the adversity - this
team went through with
injuries and and making such a huge
strategic decision there at halftime and
it paying off for him not sure he could
have handled it much better
we had Lane Kiffin on in the first hour
he said that he thinks the assistant
coaches probably brought it to food
Saban's attention to make a change in
quarterback do you believe that it would
not surprise me
I think Coach Saban obviously has final
say but Brian tables in charge at the
offense he's the head coach at the
offense and and of course you know it
wasn't going the way he thought it might
so I do think that that there's a real
possibility that first that idea was
first introduced by Brian De Vil because
he's watching it closely he's going
through the progression from the
sideline he's saying man Jalen's not
seeing the field the right way I mean we
got to make a change so I have a feeling
that it was a collaborative effort but
it might have first been brought up by
Brian De Ville certainly don't know that
for sure but of course signing off on
it's still the big dog and and what a
job he was it was by him to to make sure
it was the right call by gauging the
temperature of the team but this also
changed college football that move won a
national championship and it probably
means that you have to as your starting
quarterback now for the next couple of
years
Jalen hurts his future as a quarterback
at Alabama that may have changed his
plans as well so that there's some
fallout from this and I'm gonna guess
mostly good stuff for Alabama but I said
to kiffin what Jalen Hertz do and he
said I wouldn't be surprised if he
transfers your thoughts yeah I think
that that's a very real possibility he's
from Texas and the Texas Longhorns are
in the quarterback market and he by the
way he didn't redshirt so when he does
transfer if he does and I would assume
that's what he will do because he's a
quarterback it's hard to go to a guy
that you know you mind playing outside
linebacker are you good moving to
running back I just not a lot of guys
take kindly to that move especially at
the collegiate level and I do think that
that it would be very interesting he'd
be a sought-after guy having all the
experience that he had and know
the year to really focus and hone in on
his skills and still would have two
years of eligibility remaining so I
think it's to a show moving forward I
mean it was pretty clear and evident
that he provides a a threat through the
air that we just haven't seen from
Alabama in a few years and and he has a
young nucleus of talent around him at
one point yesterday dan they had six
true freshmen on the field on offense
yeah I know it's true freshmen in lunch
time on offense and at Alabama I think
that young group at Alabama of all
places which is a stockpiled and rich
with talent as anybody and in develops
talent I mean it's it's insane to think
of the youth that was on display last
night for them and that young group is
going to continue to grow and mature and
they'll probably win a national
championship next year wouldn't surprise
me at all but I could see Jalen Hertz
but maybe going back a little closer to
home maybe a spread style attack like at
ECU or like a Texas who you know
everyone needs a quarterback especially
in the big 12
he's Greg McElroy and the ESPN college
football analyst former Alabama
quarterback where's that national title
ring I lost it I lost another bet to fit
for it excuse me
and McLovin tried to pawn it off me
after I got him in the Wonderlic well so
Fritzi
princey has your national title ring I
didn't know that yeah on collateral
though yeah for sure so all the boys
back there you know I mean they all got
it man I miss you guys I haven't talked
to you in a while no I know you went big
time you went to the mothership beyond
ridiculous yeah I'm just trying to hang
out with you can we used to hang out all
the time
I know how's your dad doing he's doing
quite well he was having a good time
this past weekend your dad always has a
good time oh is that not the true words
have never been spoken
yeah he's a party in a box he phrased it
one time which i think is quite
appropriate given that he's now in
retirement you know it's yeah it's good
living for Big Mac just saving and this
is his last job right you don't see him
going anyplace else
I don't I really don't but if tell me
this now now you could know the NFL
better than I do and watch it closely
and of course or are so involved with
everything that you guys do on your
Sunday show I just don't think that
there's a job or an opportunity out
there right now that would really
intrigued him at the NFL level I mean is
there for you I mean I know the money
that Jon Gruden just got paid a hundred
million over ten yeah but he could get
that in Alabama though can't Greg cannon
savings already making eleven yes so
yeah it's still that that but it's that
one thing that he never got I mean he's
done everything that you can get here at
the college level I mean is there still
that that image inside him that wants to
chase a Super Bowl and does he want full
control of an NFL organization and as an
owner willing to do that I don't think
it's about the money at this point
because there's it's unrivaled he's the
greatest college coach of all time to do
what he's done in this era knowing the
competitive landscape that there is
there's no debate and I know people love
Bear Bryant and there's a lot of other
great ones out there but but it's Nick
Saban and everybody else below him at
this point so does he really feel
motivated by trying to pursue that NFL
dream I I happen to think he's not his
wife is very involved in everything that
goes on at the pro at the program and
and she wouldn't be yeah they're at the
NFL level and I think too just I think
he was such a sour situation and with
the way things went with Drew Brees and
the way they didn't clear him and it
just I don't think he likes not having
full control and I just don't know if
he's gonna get that me I felt yeah I
can't see him doing that not at this age
and you don't get to recruit in the NFL
you get the draft and there's a big
difference would you rather have Nick
Saban's career or Bill Belichick's who I
would have I would rather have Nick
Saban's because so much of what Bill
Belichick and people have will always
bring up the the argument well Bill
Belichick was nothing before Brady right
I mean I think his success is so closely
linked to one particular player the
greatest player
we've ever seen at the quarterback
position NFL history and you know I
think discredited and rightfully so with
a lot of the Patriots success whereas
when it comes Alabama Nick Saban is the
only component that's been ste from 2007
got the job until now there's been
hundreds of different players there's
been hundreds of draft picks there's
been guys that have gone on to have
tremendous careers but there's one
identifiable piece that's associated
with the Alabama Crimson Tide and that's
Nick Saban so I think that if you want
to I mean as far as how they're how
they're loved and believed in in their
particular areas of the country I think
they're close but but I think Nick Saban
just knowing that he's done it with so
many different pieces and have had to
kind of reinvent himself a few different
times it's it's really amazing the
career he's been able to put together
just like you now big time at the
mothership and he's Greg McElroy the
former Alabama quarterback please help
him find me find his national title ring
it great to talk to you please tell your
dad I said alone with you guys that's a
Greg McElroy a former friend of the show
then he got big time and now maybe he's
coming back I like that for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app